like i remember when i was in maybe
sixth grade like there was this girl
that i was in love with and i think
in sixth grade oh dude what how old are
you in sixth grade honey i thought
twelve thirteen yeah twelve thirteen so
that's not love oh i was eighty percent
heart dude look and listen to this i had
a man's dick since i was about four
so imagine my dick's been the same size
as i was four they told me who's they
they told me people the medical facility
doctors everybody medical facility
everyone get it you grew up rich you had
a medical facility okay
you had health insurance school every
sports coach dude i remember one sports
coach
taking a picture of it your dick who was
not even a pedophile no that's illegal
but he wasn't a pedophile he's just like
he was like looking at the nice tires on
a truck it was like damn
okay so okay so i am obsessed with when
you realize you were molested like the
day you realized
you just we just caught it uh here it is
hashtag time's up uh
i'm i'm here uh theo has come forward
against his childhood
basketball coach who took a picture of
his dick i know the story you're telling
yourself
right it was like a tire on a car you
were molested
i know it wasn't is this a bad time to i
was molested by kodak did i'll tell you
this i bet it took him a couple extra
minutes to develop that shot
because i had some i was throwing some
real heat but i remember coach being
like
hey hey it wasn't one my dick was so big
it wasn't one hour of photos
coach daniel i need you in here to see
this boy's dick man
that's illegal and that's molestation it
was people that were part of playstation
or
yeah it's like i think somebody touched
me i think somebody told me someone kept
fondling my mole
my mull just happens to be on the tip of
my dick dude
what a great youtube [ __ ] sequence
this is somebody that just sneaks up on
people and touches their [ __ ]
mole depending on where it is that can
be very cool
and get you on meganslaw.com so what
else or angie's list
which i mix up all the time can we
change the name of one
is it megan or angel here's the thing
you go on [ __ ] oh you get into these
uh
megan's lost heights next you know
you're looking for a carpenter next you
know you're [ __ ] molesters
you know wait you go on megan's law
looking for a carpenter well you easily
couldn't do this
they would build a children's nursery
i'm just saying there's a lot of things
going on out there that people are not
looking into
that's true it's true it's true um but i
remember so so
going back to what we're talking about i
remember being like you know in fifth
grade or something and i was in love
with this girl right and
love like everything i knew like i mean
i was just sprouting aorta's every
[ __ ] day thinking about this girl
like
and just my rib cage is just full of
just blood for this woman you're such an
artist theo you really are like a spoken
word poet
i don't know you are i mean um i mean
those people end up [ __ ]
usually selling sandwiches out of a
[ __ ] van no but you have a very uh
what's the word
florid is that the word florid look that
up
that's it like you have very like
flowery delivery oh thank you
yeah um i remember i i
the only way i could express to this
girl that i liked her was lauren
having a red or flushed complexion
elaborately or excessively
intricate or complicated well that makes
it seem pejorative
having a red flesh complexion i still
probably definitely have three
milligrams of cialis in my system from
probably a couple days ago
because i'll pop a 10 milligram just to
[ __ ] hit the street
just makes you feel a little bit of
fluff you know but i mixed up cialis
with
they're all the same are they yeah all
the antidepressants
oh no no i mean this is an
antidepressant for sure erection
really makes you stout okay okay okay
okay i thought that was viagra gives you
that friar
tuck you know what i'm saying bro that
boasts please don't call me bro
sorry thank you young lady okay thank
you
not little lady a lot of this is a land
i have a lot of rules for someone that's
sleepy i have a lot of rules
but no this is when women need to have
the most rules ladies when you're
feeling i'm about to pass out and i just
want you to know that i have strong
boundaries and i will sue you if you try
to penetrate any of my orifices oh wow
this is where i really this is you know
the um what a nantucket sleigh ride is
it's when you kill a whale and it's it
and it retaliates
that whales and mammals are the
strongest right when they're about to
die
it's like the final burst of energy and
that's me right now this is my nantucket
slay right damn this is do not call me
lady
i just want to make you as least
attracted to me as possible um
i feel like i've always been the same
i'm not attracted to you kind of yeah
but i'm gonna finish this brief story
real quick so
i was in love with this girl the only
way i could express it to her was
in my primal ways at this time i saved
one day i think it was valentine's day
i saved all the spit in my mouth one day
during class right
and after class i ran up behind her and
just spit it all right into her hair
and that was like for me it was like
this is
what did you think you were going to
accomplish by that i just hope that
somehow through it maybe through the
genetics of it and all the just the
almost like an ocean like the ocean that
had been going on in my mouth the ocean
of the [ __ ]
high and low tide of the saliva just the
the
little the soap more sober you get the
more on drugs you see
that's great it's pretty great but i
think i just wanted
i but that's how like just nervous like
a possessive because spitting on someone
is a very degrading right
thing uh it's going on out there fyi um
streets there's a lot of spitting in the
face happening uh
hashtag tinder and um and i feel like it
was like
you were trying to own her in a way or
just get your genetics onto her
lower back i think i just thought this
was the only way and i did hair you know
and i just did hair i spit into her hair
got it right yeah
i mean this is just when i look back on
it now i'm like this is the only
woman you spit on the front side of
their head yeah so you weren't that well
now i'll just lick under their chin
you're
close is that a thing no oh okay yeah if
a guy did that to me during sex
i would not be able to stop laughing for
like 45 minutes
it's called the virginia mud trail have
you heard about that it's uh
okay i thought it was the nantucket wine
taste yeah it's different
that's all that's when you have it
sleigh ride
intersects with something licking your
yeah that's when you eat grapes out from
under somebody's arm i think
the um yeah that and that's a marina del
rey wine tasting
um but no what were we talking about
before i got into that why i was talking
about fields well i have lots of
questions about the coaches that took
pictures of your dick
oh yeah i'm filing a suit after this so
i'm just trying to collect data because
i am your defense attorney
bitty basketball son we are going to get
six and four one year millions of
dollars
go blazers baby blazers for a good score
it's not that great it's not great when
your coaches are jerking off to your
girth of your day well they weren't
taking off they were it was admiration
it was like you ever been to uh rome
where you go look at the statues and
stand there and you walk away with your
wife and go get some pizza
just like that uh no no you have to pay
like three hundred dollars to look at
all that [ __ ]
no it's not enjoyable at all i went to
rome and to go see the sistine chapel it
was like eight hundred dollars i was
like [ __ ]
art what do you mean you can afford that
i know but
i mean even if you have 801 you can
technically afford it that doesn't mean
i'm about to write that check
right you know right you see a bunch of
[ __ ] i've already seen in textbooks for
30 years now you know what's crazy is my
sister can't even
read but what does it have to do with us
right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one